[Music]
you can find just about anything on the
internet but when you click a link how
do you know what's on the other side
phishing and malware are more prevalent
than ever and pose a real threat to the
personal information of yourself and
your users
you can make sure your users can quickly
identify bad sites and help protect
their information with web risk from
google cloud
webrisk contains a fully managed
database of url threats that you can
scan against to know if a url is safe
once you know if it's unsafe you can
take appropriate action such as blocking
the content or letting your users know
they shouldn't proceed
when you look up a url google checks to
see if it's in the database of known
unsafe urls this database is constantly
updated by scanning over 1 billion urls
every day
using a combination of rules machine
learning
and human analysis urls are gathered and
scanned from sources like google search
the web risk database is constantly kept
up to date so you and your users can be
confident that the analysis is reliable
and accurate so the next time
user-generated content is posted your
users can feel secure knowing that
you've protected them against any
malicious urls
getting started with the web risk lookup
api is easy once you've enabled the api
all you need to do is submit the url to
be checked against google's block list
if there's no result the url is saved
otherwise google will return what type
of threat has been detected and when
you'll want to call the api again to
check if it's still unsafe
to get started with the lookup api we'll
head over to the console from the search
at the top search for web risk so that
we can enable the api for use in this
google cloud project
now we can create a service account to
securely call the api so click
credentials and then create credentials
we'll make a service account called
webriskrunner
once that's created we can download the
service account key to easily make api
calls on behalf of our service account
now we can switch to cloud shell or you
can use a local environment with g-cloud
already set up
first we can set the application
credentials to point to the service
account key then all we need to do is
run this command
this command makes a request to the web
risk api using our service account
credentials
here we're looking for malware on the
url testsafebrowsing.appspot.com
s malware.html
and the response confirms that malware
has been detected on the url as well as
an expiration time so that we could
cache the result locally and know when
to rescan this particular url
there's more than just the lookup api if
you're looking for lower latency or for
private scanning webrisk also offers an
offline database through the update api
for even more details you can use the
evaluation api to get a confidence score
and the submission api to report
suspected urls
there's a lot of urls out there so get
started for free with webrisk today to
protect your users check out the link to
learn more
[Music]
you